hello everyone it is 2015 and I'm
playing I am fish let's begin swim
towards the light I can do this
I can manage Hey look I'm doing it
alright so cute that's actually adorable
Oh God the controls are so weird so far
I love this game
okay I did it okay I'm in a glass bowl
nice oh wow so I swims in the water
still oh gosh that's a lot harder than I
thought
Oh No where am i I'm so bad at games
dude I'm doing it somehow I imagine me
magically yeah that's the word I'm
pulling through
WAIS is so annoying oh no I'm dead
epic hello that's so sad I'm crying
this fish is cried tears stop no more
fish sleep say it with me
sleep sleep alright what are you
planning to do this holiday that's right
sleep sleep check out ugly Christmas
sweater calm and order now to get it
before Christmas unpause okay let's try
that again
I can definitely do this oh my god he
changed direction are you kidding me
that is so dumb die already
cheese says alright well let's do that
again
this fish game makes no sense and it
makes me angry already I did it I'm
probably the greatest gamer there's ever
been
thank you alright here we go how am I
supposed to control that okay I made it
making game okay so what are the
controls game developer yes so like what
buns do it yes
alright we're heading out I think maybe
hopefully I did it no one's ever done
should I do it oh god okay oh please
don't fall down
thank you thank you I've managed to pull
through thank you alright I hit a
checkpoint what who I go for we're oh
wait what is that definitely here okay I
can hear the waves there's hope let's
just take it easy oh yeah oh yeah
what oh just died okay is this one of
the game starts getting hard fine oh god
how how am I supposed to hit that okay I
hit it I'm male oh god no you stay gay
you deserve to dead just die my god
look he's happy he's fine he's fine he
was fine oh god hey hey stop stop all
right easy easy does it easy does it
swing back swing back hit that chair I
did it how I hit the share so I think
this is an early version of the game
which is why it's so good yes I did it I
did it I did the thing I did the thing I
did it swing back oh okay I did it I did
it I did it I'm good I'm good at games
look gamers look are you kidding me go
don't I hit the checkpoint I hit it I
don't know how Oh another Bowl is
cracked I don't know where to go here
walk it's not hard to walk stinky fish
oh god don't
there we go nailed it oh no oh I think
I'm I think oh my god I hit it perfectly
look at a bit it nice Oh God
Oh mattress yeah all right let's make
sure we get the checkpoint cool now what
oh I see a mattress I see it you just
hit it here oh there's plenty of
mattresses who plays them there Oh Oh
God okay I did it nice now I just gotta
make it to the ocean
full speed ahead this is so sad wait I'm
right there I can make it no this is so
sad fish didn't make it just gotta go
fast fast through swim through fast
Oh God Oh God
[Music]
oh I can hit the sewers perfect and I
made it in I made it in I made it
that's [ __ ] alright slow we're doing
this slow god damn it have these people
heard of traffic laws Jesus Christ
alright nice second one let the second
one is it just random I could speed good
woman yeah I can do it I can do it I can
do it I can do it I can still do it why
is there a crosswalk here this is a lot
about our society this is a lot about
how society doesn't care about disabled
people right this is so [ __ ] lame
stop just either stop or go I don't care
which one I'm just gonna go for it oh
okay no you did not have to drive there
alright good speed good speed good speed
go go go go go super speed whoa huh yes
okay did it
nailed it just hit the water what
happens when I hit some water how how
you saw that cool alright so I guess I
got a deal with the ball Oh God stupid
stink of stink all right just go I'm so
sick of this just go speed
[Music]
this part sucks come on speed speed
speed
stop speed speed speed
stop stop yes yes easy
alright alright now we just got to score
a something glass bottle doesn't
randomly combust Oh God
slow no it's a lot harder to control
than it looks okay just so we're clear
ah freed them I like this a random
platform for I'm still stuck in the
glass all right sure next level let's do
it alright alright alright I'm just a
fish my owner forgot the bat to me I
must escape they set that up those
[ __ ]
come on okay I guess we got a through
the hard rap fine sorry
TV sorry limp no lamp lamp lamp maybe I
do it no god the music makes me want to
kill myself the lamb okay cool
did it oh yeah yeah it's you yeah it's
you or me lamp I don't care what it
takes
really oh my god you're so annoying
stop fighting you will not win you will
not win this fight that's where I'll amp
each I hope you die lamp no hit it hit
it yeah that's right lamb yeah is that a
propane tank oh okay alright we gotta
hit the lighter god I hit the ladder
Brunt ladder fish be like that's funny
okay here we go
here we go nailed it dude he's fine look
at him hello sup I'm fine actually I'm
fine I can flip Darren Felix oh no oh no
this is so sad I gotta hit it hard from
the side nice nice the checkpoint
Chaplin trampling I'm dying
my last word Epstein out there right all
right we go this way what did I just
pick up right that tui
hi I'm getting good I'm getting good I'm
getting good I'm not good here we go we
go down here will you bounce up the roof
and then oh no okay ah no no no I did
not click out did I click out don't make
me do all of that all that effort all
that progress are you kidding me I have
to fight lamp again [ __ ] off lamp get
AIDS
oh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah Earth can
suck it
earth can suck it that is right alright
nice
step aside propane tanks yeah
what how
you
[ __ ] sake I click out again I'm such a
[ __ ] I don't wanna play the lamp again
no fish no fish no fish no this is so
sad he died again eat [ __ ] lamp Earth
can suck my dick no no all right made it
made it for the fifth time am I not
supposed to drop there oh I thought I
was supposed to drop okay and how how I
managed how I managed oh wait I did I
managed I managed okay cool so cool I
swim in sewer I'm free oh god oh god Wow
okay hurts oh Jesus how do I jump how do
I get out of here yeah this is like save
Willy but she also Willy that's his name
that's funny up up up up up up up up up
up up yeah yeah alright alright I think
I did it they won't get it games out
damn it
Oh God
that's great I got a better aquarium now
gamers it's like getting a brand new PC
I feel powerful I feel strong I feel
like oh yeah you like that you like that
hey hey oh so now you have problem with
it as soon as I'm free this has a lot
about society
okay I'm alive okay come on stop let me
yeah if he wait for fish makes it this
far you can at least let him live stop
don't ever hate me I hate myself hey hey
okay
no one will hate me no one stop take
your stinky beard and drink your soy go
away go away go wait story sorry so it's
to please please please I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Oh take a sting oh no no no no this stop
shut up
oh god this is actually so difficult how
am I gonna get past
Oh No don't touch me he touched me
illegally he touched me legally oh god I
die my final message he is stirred in
brain ah I knew it
I always knew it why does he say it like
he's amazed and then he wants to stop me
from thriving in society explain
yourself
this is like the plot of a Pixar film
isn't it oh wait it literally is hit me
as I said it all right we can make it a
lot easier to control this sign don't
hit how I'm still alive I can still make
it
oh god I'm dead change the world I am
speed at the corner the corner gets
super speedy and yeah corner shut up
sorry lent man don't ever speak to me
okay alright and then we got to make a
big turn here oh this is so much easier
yeah yeah yeah oh my god I'm good at
games
my final message BP is small now [ __ ]
off you do not touch me why does he have
to do that why does he have to flip it
damn it now I'm angry I'm really angry
for real I'm gonna take the right lane
shut up
yes crisis averted crisis averted crisis
inverted Oh God okay alright I made it
I'm a damn it I made it easy easy peasy
golden peace PC golden peepee yeah
golden golden people : PB
don't touch me [ __ ] you were not
even close to me my final message
friends is not that good
oh no I'm cancelled now I like this part
even though it's hard it's still more
fun to control I got rather they wish
they made that level more difficult than
the controls better than the controls
just being completely random except the
stones are pretty random
this is right last time cuz I think I'm
doing pretty well no oh my gosh oh gosh
oh gosh oh gosh no oh I think I did it
oh god now I really don't want to [ __ ]
up all right and I just did
don't touch me white man oh come on dude
yeah yeah yeah we're out this easier I
can't tell this sucks
this [ __ ] sucks it just [ __ ] sucks
that's so bull
don't you ever [ __ ] hay me no one
haze the hey man
you're a rock star get your show on can
I go on the edge here if I can and
that's a shortcut I don't think I can
I'm going for it gamers I made a mistake
we all make them don't touch me I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine there's plenty water
illegal are you kidding me alright new
tactic momentum we got to get momentum
all right we got momentum there it is
now it's easy I would keep it left and
then we go right shut up this is the
tricky part
especially if you almost okay somehow
managed Oh God I'm doing it
you'd bad enough can touch me come on
I could literally not do this more
perfectly ocean motion Oh God
oh no oh oh god swims left swim left yes
easy that was easy
I'm not gonna lie too easy they should
patch that to make it harder
I am fish I read them this is very
little relatable because this is how I
feel at the club
how do I get out let me live it's gotta
be a hole I'm out all right here we go
nailed it nailed it nailed it
oh absolutely get in get in I think I
got in i got in i got in i'm in get out
get out of my sight get out of my sight
get out my side don't touch me don't
touch me i'm the king of the dance floor
okay don't ever touch me why does it
music awkwardly stop and go okay respect
vicinity respect your dignity respect
pain I just thought I'd step up my
commentary there for a while
nice to say thanks for sticking with my
channel I you slimy snake of ass yeah
yeah yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's it Oh get the tattoo yeah get it
to TIA
I got the to TIA I got it nice okay so
now we go this way we got to get to the
VIP gamers that's where all the hot
babes are are we going down here oh I
see backstage yes wait I don't think
there's anything there where am I
supposed to go
all right through the dance floor it is
excuse me why is this Sophie relatable
excuse me just uh just going okay sorry
I used to work at a nightclub - it was
not amping sink could that be it I'm
supposed to like jump out and hit the
hole cuz that's just like real life it's
that's the case Arlis
ah wait there were stairs here oh my god
I was going down the stairs I don't know
if that's better or worse than what I
was trying to do Jeanne sighs oh god oh
go i made a poopy in my panty I just got
a hold back
oh no there's a corner there nice oh
nice yeah Oh God
thoughts Oh God Cecil Tito Tito it
though we know you know we know we know
[Music]
i time is not correction my peepee not
Direction come on come on that's illegal
I'm going full speed how the timing
could not be more awful kidding me
oh no it's snowy nice no are you kidding
me
don't touch me checkpoint I were going
through dance floor I'm so done with the
game seriously
oh nice he gave me forward momentum
that's so cool
no I don't want to talk to you no I
don't like you I don't like it I think
we gotta make it to the toilet
I like how their movement is completely
[ __ ] random don't touch me girl don't
touch me don't touch me don't touch me
I'm a fish and a shank yes I used new
words wait am i back at the bar no no oh
God
where's the checkpoint there it is I see
the shucks point nice yeah boy
alright handicapped ramp or stairs oh
these are the tough questions in life
guys I have a confession to make I also
use the handicapped toilets all the time
and I don't feel bad about it for a
single second listen if the toilet is
full it's full you gotta go you got a
bro bo don't touch me he touched me
alright stairs citizen I'm not doing
that old spiel again
Oh stairs not so bad do I go to the exit
or the toilet I feel like oh no you
[ __ ] I am speed I am fast I don't touch
me [ __ ]
yes what kind of dips we'll just push an
aquarium on the dance floor I want
answers
alright there it is there's a checkpoint
it's in my vicinity
oh yes yes I go poopy now oh yes nice
nice sup ladies he just kicked it I'm in
the bear are you drink a bear am i in
its digestive system Oh what just
happened to this game this is not
illegal That moment when you drank a
[ __ ] fish can't relate what happens
when the bar is full I'll join the conga
train it site right there's another
chick one here why no this is where I
started or is it I'm so confused
okay here we go now I can take it oh my
god we're really running out of time
here bro literally anywhere I did it
yeah I did it
I made a poopie in my mouth a mouse
poopie hey yeah yeah yeah we're going
fast so fast ow
we've been through a lot today gamers
but we made a guy damnit sweet victory
yeah remember kids pee is stored in the
balls thank you for watching
I am fish if you enjoyed subscribe smash
like suka be up merch out now brick
villas m.com says pewdiepie and i see
you tomorrow bye bye were all excited
about the new game that's coming out and
I can't wait to play it it's